Oh stay in den mother you engage me
panting Faisal targets no no my side
measures ecosystems crushing boiler
flowing emissions are leaping no
indigenous rise well here in Copenhagen
it's the final day of negotiations but
behind closed doors negotiators are
still struggling to work out the details
of a climate deal a deal on forestry
looks much closer however no one has
read for reducing emissions from
deforestation and forest degradation
this could be the most successful
outcome of the copenhagen climate talks
if it is passed it will provide a
financial means for nations to protect
their forests rather than destroying
them red is a huge issue you
deforestation accounts for up to twenty
percent of world emissions so designing
a system that addresses that is really
the low-hanging fruit here it's
something that has to be done in
Copenhagen that was Amanda Kray a
journalist who this week received an
earth Journalism Award here in
Copenhagen for her expose a of
disturbing practices among those
receiving money to protect forests in
Papua New Guinea ensuring that the money
ends up in the right hands is one of the
most challenging aspects of red another
really contentious issue is how to
preserve the rights of indigenous
peoples who live in forests than you
want to remain there
arguably the biggest issue for red
though is ensuring that the carbon
actually stays locked up in the forest
and that means the government will have
to be honest about the extent of which
they're logging and burning trees and
that might be a big ask I think the
lesson is that without accountability
and transparency this system won't work
it won't work for the indigenous people
who live in the forest it won't work for
the carbon traders won't work for the
carbon market and it certainly won't
work for the forest so I think it's
really important for the leaders who are
here this week to ensure that they come
up with a red system that works for
everybody and doesn't just benefit a
select few so that's exactly what
negotiator is here in Copenhagen are
trying to do working late into the night
to try to hammer out a deal on forestry
today I met up with chief negate see a
sheriff or paraguay to find out just how
close we are to reaching agreement on
red yes they're very close we just need
ministers to erase one of the few
remaining brackets and we'll have a deal
you mentioned that there are some areas
still in brackets which means there
unresolved can you tell us what those
issues are exactly as usual money of
course funding who's going to pay for
this and how much and well actually
what's going to be the role of recipient
countries is that really clearly defined
of course we have to protect the forests
in our territory but there are many
other details like monitoring and
evaluation and reporting of the actions
to stop deforestation so that's all in
brackets and we'll need our ministers to
really put the best political will to to
get rid of them some of the NGOs here
we're concerned that the final red deal
may not actually protect natural forests
but would protect forests more generally
can you clarify what the overall goal of
the red deal will be well we have
safeguards against the conversion of
natural forests but we still have
read especially red class as it's being
called now has the potential of
promoting monoculture plantations
because of the dubious definitions used
by this convention so we still have that
problem and you mentioned financing
earlier a couple of days ago you know
there was an announcement the 3.5
billion would be put forward over the
next three years to kickstart red
financing it does that fool very short
if the mark of what's needed what's
really needed in terms of financing and
how close are we to getting that it's
very difficult to put a number because
forests are not just carbon forests are
a wealth of incredible wealth of
different values so it's a very very
difficult that's a very tricky territory
we of course think that we need much
more than that in the order of about 10
15 times more just to get started but to
hazard a guess you're saying maybe 30
belly in a year is about the source of
finance and we're talking about well yes
that's getting closer yes much closer
and so you mentioned the importance of
forest can you tell us a bit about how
important forests are in Paraguay and
why you know you're so keen to protect
them yes well paraguay I used to have
very exuberant and lush subtropical
forests from the almost 9 million
hectares we used to have 50 years ago we
have scattered patches adding up to
about 700,000 Hector's now so that's
tremendous loss so if we don't see an
overall climate deal agreed here in the
next couple of days where does that
leave the red deal do we need an overall
you know agreement from cop15 for red to
get kick-started the agreement here is
like going to be enough we know that but
the National processes will not get
started without an agreement at this
level so we do need the highest level
political commitment to back the red
efforts so I hear that you were up late
last night negotiating can you tell us a
bit about that hasn't been a long haul
and you know do you think it's over Just
quite yes or do you expect another
all-nighter this evening as you can see
it from my face yes we were really
really until very early this morning in
a negotiating room until about
four-thirty that's later laughs and it's
a second time in a row or actually the
third so we haven't been sleeping that
much we have to be prepared for tonight
as well because we want a very
substantial very as meaningful deal out
of Copenhagen we just don't want any
type of deal we want to work extremely
hard to get the best we can get from
this process we're still waiting to get
the final word on red today is the
official deadline by which world leaders
must agree to a climate deal here in
Copenhagen for talking to anyone here it
seems that that might be postponed by a
day or two once that happens we'll be
back with the video giving an assessment
of what's been agreed here at cobb 15 in
the meantime I'm off to do some star
spotting there that Obama's arrived
Oh stay in den mother you engage me
panting weasel targets not in my side
measures ecosystems crushing palm oil
flowing emissions are leaping no
indigenous voice feel like the training
and bacon species for respect versus too
much fossil fuels tree shapes or no I
know big bad looking subsidy